Unions in France
are protesting one more time
over the president's
pension reform,
and they say this will
likely be one of the last.
They are trying to push lawmakers
to reverse course.
Almost two months after the government
raise the retirement age
from 62 to 64,
March has got underway across France
and is estimated about 600,000
people have turned out.
And these process protests
I should say which started months ago
if you remember
we covered them on the show.
I've seen their share of violence
on the sideline
and some protests even stormed
the headquarters
of the Paris 2024 Olympic Games earlier.
Melissa Bell was there
and she's standing by now for us in Paris
and Melissa,
you've been across
many of the recent protests out of Paris
that we've covered.
How does this one did work,
this one compared
I mean, did
the protests achieve anything here?
Well, it was
much quieter than some of the protests
we've seen in these last few weeks.
There was a little tear gas.
There were a few scuffles,
but nothing on the level
of what we'd seen
last month or indeed the month before.
In terms of the numbers, we had been
the authorities had been preparing
for 600,000.
In the end, the actual figure is 281,000.
So really under that
31,000 here in Paris.
So it was much smaller protests.
And that, Isa, is partly
because the main union has announced
that this was likely to be the last one.
Essentially,
this reform is going to become law.
There's very little
that can be done about it.
But I think they will have been heartened
by the numbers
that have turned out
so consistently week
in, week out
over the course of the last six months.
This began back in January.
So they have sent a strong signal
that they will keep going to the streets.
And I think it is for the autumn
and the future reforms
that Emmanuel Macron has planned
for his last four years in office
that they really have their eye on.
Of course, what this latest
series of protests has done is remind us
of just how much a part of French
political life
protests are in this country.
In fact,
we got to catch up with one journalist
who essentially makes a living
from just that
Another pitched battle
between protesters and police
in the heart of Paris.
The images captured by a journalist
who's made this his specialty.
Klimala has covered every major French
protest for the last seven years.
His focus to document the many uprisings
against the government
and tell the stories
of the anger behind them.
They could not show those be used up.
The money is there, says one protester.
We just have to go and get it.
Traveling across the city, the protesters
hush each other
as they get closer
to the Euronext Stock Exchange.
There, they pause the
then charge
through the flares in the smoke
that engulfs the building lobby.
The sound of anger at the French
president.
The shocking scenes.
But for Paris, nothing new.
The protests
against the government's
upping of the pension age from 62 to 64
are just the latest round
to draw people to the streets.
I didn't really see a party in Paris.
There are protests almost every day.
Some smaller.
Some bigger
because in France we are used to it.
As soon as something goes wrong.
The French protest,
the hardest to cover,
he says,
were the yellow vest protests of 20, 19
and 2020
avec le
police recommended for the police,
the protesters.
We've never seen protests that violent.
Everyone was a little shaken.
Everyone was a little changed.
Over the years.
The 25 year old has been on the receiving
end of rubber
bullets, police batons
and angry tussles with protesters Being a
journalist is little protection, he says.
Several times
I found myself
in the middle of the police charges.
They hit me with their shields,
even though they could see
I was a journalist
and they could have avoided me.
But despite the dangers, images
like these have been earning
Eleanor a decent
living for the last seven years.
Covering hundreds of protests, she says.
In fact, the manifestos went bust.
Once the demonstration is over,
everyone goes home
and life goes back to normal.
You'll probably see bus stops
that have been shattered,
but life goes on
and everything is okay
for the Parisians
who go back out for a walk
when the protest is done.
In a city
where the culture of protest runs
deep, it's just another day
and another cleanup of the streets of
the French capital.
Is even as this
latest round of protest
now seems to be petering out.
What we look ahead to is a September
where essentially the French will start
working longer incrementally.
The government has got its way, Isa.
And this is all for us
and Paris is for you.
Thanks very much, Melissa.